[Music]
you
hallo YouTube just love us and my
friends this is guns in here welcome to
my ninth episode of in love in Tulsa
cylinder puta from the black perspective
in this episode we are going to look at
some of the critical sidelines which
arises after the move 10 h4 and the
mordor goes as follows
Quinn to d1 Quinn to g6 Knight to c3
Knight G to e7 and now in the last
episode we have look at the second main
line with start with Bishop to e3 but in
this episode we are going to look at the
MU H 4 which is absolute the main line
and the most popular choice
well White's idea is very obvious he
wants to play H Phi so that's why D Phi
is no longer a good option for the black
and accordingly black has to play as Phi
in order to prevent this pawn to move
further
okay as I highlighted over here Bishop
to g5 is probably the most critical
response however time to time white has
unleashed this side line moves such as
Bishop to e3 and rook to h3 and this is
exactly this video is all about the
first move I want to consider is Bishop
to e3 which is in fact played in more
than 30 games and compared to the last
video I think the only difference here
is both the side has committed that
phone which in fact helping the black
let me show you what I mean so a line
will not change as we will continue with
this traumatic break defy and you
already know that if I'd keep capturing
this pawn with the piece let's say
Knight captures d5 Knight captures d5
and Queen captures defy then after
Bishop to e6 more or less he loses the
e4 pawn has only way to defend this pawn
is to play Queen to d3
but after Knight to before in fact the
e4 pawn is a goner and dispositions are
good for black camp
so obviously the main move in this
position is he captures defy but after
that we will continue with this team at
ik idea night to be for attacking the
weak c2 spot and the only good way to
defend this pawn is to play Bishop to d3
pay attention guys as now comes the big
difference of why displaying the MU H 4
is pretty bad for the white as without
this move I have recommended the Moon
Knight captures d3 but specially in this
line we are going to play this very
tricky move Bishop to F are pressurizing
tremendously to this c2 spot
well white has two choices number one
Castle is a very bad idea
and the simple refutation goes as follow
Bishop kept his d3 pawn captures d3
and now black regain his pawn back with
Knight B captures d5
after the following sequence night
captors defy night captors defy and the
move Bishop to c5 which stop black to
castle on the Kings side black has this
very nice move Knight to a4 and I think
after this we get a huge advantage in
the middle game
there is a double threat and the only
good way to defend this threat is Queen
to f3 not only defending g2 but come to
attacking on b7 however black has the
equally good response namely Queen to g4
well white can't even touch on b7 the
simple reason is after Knight to e2
check King to h2 and Queen to h4 it's a
pictures checkmate haha
so that's not a possibility and again if
white really wants to avoid the Queen
trade and defend all the track he has
the only response Quint we for which
create multiple threats
however just one new castle on the Queen
side and black is completely winning
the D 3 point is hanging if white try to
defend the spawn with either of the rook
let's say rook F to d1 then after rook
captures d3 black is instantly winning
as if you take this rook then after
Knight to h3 white will lose the Queen
so that's not a great option for a white
and as per the engine the basement
suggested is Bishop to e7 which has an
intention of rook to Sivan check this is
not going to work out because of this
simple idea Knight to e2 check King to
s2 now we exchange the Queen and then
put of a rook on this wonderful second
rank which obviously conforms the black
advantage
you
so castle is too much dangerous for the
white accordingly White has to play the
base reply namely Bishop captures f5 but
even after this we will recapture with
overnight and now I think White has a
bigger problem as Black has multiple
threads number one Knight captures e3
and then night capture c2 which will nab
the rook in the corner and number two
Queen captures g2 which also create some
great headache for the white camp
well it's not clear how white can save
all this threat as the only move Bishop
to c5 completely fails due to the
following tactic Queen captures g2
attacking the rook rook to a phone and
now you will see why h4 is such a bad
move as Black has this lethal reply can
you see it
yup Knight to g3 hahaha
and white is completely busted
obviously you can't take this night as
after nightcap see to what has to give
up the Queen and apart from is if the
chest and in suggest that White has to
play King 2d to then something horrible
it goes in the opening stage here the
simple refutation is you can take this
rope with a check and after Queen
captures have fun and the move quint we
have three black emerge with an exchange
and the tactical point is if white
continue it Bishop captures before then
after Queen to f4 we cared our piece
back and in fact win the game very
quickly
the second and the most trickiest move
in this position is rook to h3 which
none other than Vladimir Kramnik has
played in one of the game so we need to
take it very seriously why it's idea is
very obvious he wants to play rook to g3
however I think it has a clear downside
namely it allows what black was to do d5
okay rook to g3 what else and now I
propose this very interesting piece
sacrifice with Bishop to g4
all the game in the database continue we
have three however if you open and place
the move Bishop to e2 then it's not a
good choice and after Bishop exchange
the resulting position are quite good
for the black camp I have attached the
whole line in the PG in which you can
check it out but let's look at what
happens after f3 has this move confirms
that black is going to lose a piece
except this is exactly black wants
here the fun start with this very nice
move d captures evo
now White has two choices whether to
grab the peace or to continue with night
captures evil
if your opponent continue with this
timid response then after rook to d8 I
think fight position is completely
losing he can't play Quint we to do to
Knight to d4 and the only response
available in this position is Bishop to
d3
[Music]
even after this black get this instant
advantageous position with f5 attacking
the night it doesn't matter where ever
this night goes let's say Knight to g5
and engine suggests that after Queen to
f6 black has a good advantage however I
think it's bit complicated and my own
suggestion here is you play this very
simple line efore and as you will see
that after the forcing sequence
F captures g4e captures v3 if you
captured on that file then it will
really help black rook development so
accordingly group captures d3 is a
neutral response but after the following
continuation rook captures d3 Queen
captures d3 and the moon F captures g4
if white moves Queen anywhere then
Knight to d4 is a very strong reply so
by force white has to exchange the Queen
which again usually favors the black
because of the following sequence Knight
captures g6 attacking on h4 so g3 and
now comes the sting in the tail
Knight to d4 looking for the juicy fork
and when white defenders
I hope you see the end Hyup Knight to a5
and by force we are winning the pawn and
this endgame is hugely favoring the
black camp
the point is why can't even save this
pawn due to the simple technique night
capsules f4 pawn takes f4 and now Knight
to h4 and H and G pawn are running down
and nobody can stop
okay finally let's check out what
happens if white grab the piece with F
captures g4
well first we are going to play the move
group to D H attacking the Queen and
what has the only response namely Bishop
to d2 now comes the only memory marker
which you have to remember in this
position play this star mu fi and after
this however white plays black is
winning in all the variations
let's see each bite on first move
Quintus even is a pretty bad one the
simple reason is after each captures g4
black get three pawn for a piece as s4
is likely to be disappeared from the
board and if white continue with this
critical line namely Bishop to g5 we
have this forcing sequence f4 attacking
the rook rook captures g4 Queen to a5
again Bishop to e2 is the only move but
after f3 g captures f3 and II kept as f3
by force black is getting the piece back
with a huge advantage on the board
you
the second mood GFI is a pretty bad and
after that black is immediately winning
with this forcing sequence F for root 2
H 3 is the only response and after that
the winning short did you spot it yup
it's night to be 4 and the game is over
as black as a simple threat namely III
and then deliver a folk on C to
something which white cannot stop as if
he try to defend on C to it either Queen
or oak let's say rook to c1 then III and
that Bishop is a complete corner
finally let's look at what happens after
rook to e3 which was the choice of
Vladimir Kramnik
but unfortunately again this is not a
right option as after the MU s captures
G for again the spawn mass are very
annoying for the white camp and on top
of everything H for porn is falling well
in the game Cromley continue with King
to f2 and just lost within the 26 moves
so you can check out that game in the PG
n however the important point I like to
highlight here that if white continue
with g3 try to save this pawn
then he get even worse position by the
following model night to d4 threat is
very obvious Knight to f3 and nabbing
the bishop and obviously when white
tried to stop this threat with Bishop to
e2 after the following sequence Knight
to f3 check Bishop captures f3 and now G
captures f3 finally the g3 pawn will
fall and if white become greedy and try
to hang on to this pawn with King to f2
then he get this rude shock rook to h4
hahaha and the game is all guys as after
G captures at for Queen check came to
even and Quinta Jeevan a deadly
checkmate occurred just within 22 moves
of the game
you
that's it guys after watching this video
I am sure now you are confident enough
to make these sidelines in the
tournament practice thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment and I will meet
you in my next episode very soon bye and
take care